Luke and Jake here at the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel and we're here in the
beaches of Alaska we're surf fishing for
halibut truck camping eating good food
and having a good time yeah
me and Tommy we're heading out to go
catch some hooligan who would again
oh it's nasty weather out there top
here's where it gets wet
come on let's go
let's go try a spot with a little bit
less wind shall we yeah let's take a
look at this spot
you got it there you go
there's this little fish called the
candle fish or a hooligan or a smell and
every spring they come and migrate from
the ocean up into the rivers
right there now that's the spot you want
the one that's out of the rain
that right there is a hooligan
there we go got two
I got another one Tom
all right you go for it I like this
thing where you just catch him you got
more time
there you go
they call him a candle fish because when
you dry them up you can light them on
fire and they burn like gasoline there's
so much oil in it
just turn it up
hi this is
[Applause]
[Music]
dude
check out this hook and he's got bite
marks on him some fish or seal or
something went after him everything
wants to eat hooligan
not bad for about 30 minutes
Tom are you cold yes it is miserable out
there but we did all right we got a
bucket of hooligan
all righty dude it's hooligan time now
people eat the hooligan all the time you
can fry them you can smoke them you can
extract the oil from them and use it in
cooking and preserving food but it also
makes really good halibut bait and
that's what I'm going to be using mine
for
hooligan are an excellent bait but
they're kind of soft and they tear off
the hook really easy so we're gonna
brine them to make them last longer and
to toughen up this is a product called
Brine and bite from a company called
procure
I'm just gonna go ahead and let those
Hooligans sit in the brine overnight all
right the fish have been sitting here
for a couple days and they're all brined
up
foreign
all right you ready to go hella bit
fishing yeah let's do it
all right let's check this out
this is cook Inland this is a wonderful
place to catch halibut you can see
there's a halibut boat there and there
this time of year the Halibut come in
shallow to chase hooligan and Herring
and other Bait fish and so I'm gonna get
my rods up and hopefully as the tide
comes in we're gonna get ourselves a
halibut it's kind of windy and cold
today but luckily we got a spot right by
the water so we can watch our rods from
the comfort of our car
I'm gonna drive the truck onto the beach
a little bit but gotta be careful if it
gets stuck that tide comes in and your
truck's gone we got like a 20-foot tide
here
foreign
it's always good luck when you find a
pair of pliers
we got two rods in the water now we wait
got my fishing rods right there I can
see what's going on
there you go Bud a little Hawaiian sweet
bread rolls with some Nutella and banana
not too bad
this gentleman just offered me some
salmon guts for halibut bait
oh that's awesome they're real tough
meat too is hard to steal not like that
Frozen herring
I just saw these guys over here pull out
a remote controlled boat to take their
bait out
that is slick I've heard about these for
uh shark fishing down in Florida but
I've never seen one in real life yeah
they're pretty interesting this one came
with a fish finder it's got a sonar on
it uh it's also got this little bait
launcher on the back too oh nice so when
you flip the switch on there it just
opened and it comes out the back that is
cool man I hope you get a big one man
thank you it's a lot of money to spend
on a remote control boat but it keeps
you from having to buy specialized surf
rods and surf rails and that'll save you
a lot of money
all right I think it's time to check my
bait and move my rods up the beach
[Applause]
that right there is a giant sculpin or
we used to call these Irish Lords
growing up look at a huge mouth on them
and they're covered in spines
they're all so tough as Nails well there
you go that's probably what's been
stealing my bait
all right got the truck moved the Rod's
baited up I think it's time to start
thinking about dinner
oh that's a piece of coal right there I
will throw that on the fire there's
several places around here where coal
comes up out of the beach
it's another chunk
s
give you a sunny day with a light Breeze
and dry wood man making the fires easy
think I need to sanitize my grill a
little bit looks a little gooey
we got some great food for dinner
tonight I'm excited we have a ton of
shish kebabs here
pork loin with chunks of apple cinnamon
and Nutmeg
this bacon wrapped jalapeno stuffed with
the Savory cream cheese
the appended dates wrapped in bacon is
one of my absolute favorites
chunks of chicken breast wrapped in more
bacon
and chunks of chicken breast seasoned
with Moroccan razel hanui it's a
Moroccan spice blend it's fabulous
look at that bacon wrapped chicken
breast try this
we're gonna try this jalapeno here
the cream cheese I put inside the
jalapenos has chai cilantro lime Peppers
it's it's fabulous
you like the pork and apple
my absolute favorite is the bacon
wrapped dates I had these for the first
time this fall in Portugal I've been
making them ever since
oh good
a little bit cold okay here come here
I'll take you back in
you get enough food or you want more
there you go you good
oh hey it's a little windy out here
still
this is a little bit too much food for
me and Jake I think we might need to
share some you guys want some food I got
a little extra here oh man that'd be
awesome bacon wrapped dates here try one
of those really
looks like you guys are bringing game
though that was a good looking good
looking brats and dogs man
you can see a guy way out there on a
kayak he's paddling out his bait
it's the same Technique we use when
we're shark fishing off the beach in
Florida it allows you to fish way
further out and use much bigger baits
oh I think I just got a hit there I just
saw that Rod just go crazy
got something on here for sure
oh double sculping
this little tiny fish can fit my whole
hand in his mouth
the Tide's getting a little too close to
the truck for my liking I think we need
to pick it up and move
I got the rods repositioned and the high
tide is going to be in about two or
three hours so this is the beginning of
the sweet time hopefully we'll get a
hell of it
Jay Hey Jake what's the matter
you need to poop okay really badly okay
I got you uh okey dokey well
[Music]
all right you good everything work out
excellent
all buried you ready a little tired Jake
oh yeah I'll get your sleeping bag out
we'll get you a bed made up
[Music]
all right there you go buddy all right
you all snuggled in there bud
good
a bunch of people down there picking
something up off the beach I'm gonna go
check it out
oh yeah look at that it's almost like
sea glass and that's a type of Agate huh
oh that is way cool she says she makes
stuff out of them that's neat now that
high tides are on the corner a lot more
people have showed up
we'll see if anyone lands a hell of it I
think it's time to freshen up my baits
big sculpin
Tide's coming in pretty quick that fire
Pit's almost underwater
check it out these guys are going to
launch his zodiac off the beach and go
fishing that way
looks like a lot of work but might do
the trick hey buddy I just realized
something yeah
we didn't need our cookies
oh nice peanut butter cookie there
oh Rod just got bit down there I just
saw someone running
all right time to check my bait
iOS category four that's got a good hit
I saw it hit hard enough to pull a
little slack we'll see so buddy do you
enjoy the movie yeah you know what time
it is though
all right buddy you going to bed
all right get snuggle up buddy well that
one rod got a good bite nothing happened
so uh we need to check the bait
there you go
I got some big hits right there
oh what do we got
oh that is certainly a big sculpin
size of that thing
all right I thought we had something
there yeah it's been nothing but sculp
and sculp and sculping here it's a
little disappointing the Tide's going
out pretty aggressively and it's late I
think it's time to get some sleep so I'm
gonna go ahead and reel up these rods
I'll tell you what guys I am exhausted
and Jacob looks pretty comfortable back
there so I'm thinking instead of setting
up a tent I might just uh Zonk out right
here on this front seat good night guys
I woke up a little bit cold had to turn
the car on get the seat warmers going
just slightly over freezing outside
get up in a little bit
we get dressed well things were pretty
slow yesterday when I didn't see anyone
catching any fish so I think we should
try another Beach and mix things up a
little bit
you know I've had a lot of people online
tell me that I need professional help
and I think they might be right we
didn't catch anything yesterday so we
are gonna go meet up with a fishing
guide who specializes in surf fishing
for halibut we're going to see if the
professional can't put us on some fish
oh hey Randy how you doing I'm doing
well sir how are you doing good so we're
gonna be going fishing with Randy here
and his company is compassion through
fishing and I I hear you are the
grandfather of halibut fishing from the
beach around here yeah so we're
introducing a little bit of surf fish
into the communities up here helping
folks to be successful from the beach
yes sir you you looking forward to it
yeah all right
thank you
here
[Music]
awesome yeah
[Applause]
yeah these gentlemen down here have got
a bait Cannon this is my good friend
bait Cannon Bob right here
we love this pleasure to meet you
peace grab it I'll use it again
oh nice it's a giant spit wad gun they
wrapped their lead and bait and
newspaper shove it down the barrel and
shoots out one thing you learned about
surf fishermen is they are obsessed
about trying to get out just a little
bit further
yeah
the little the little flounder how on
Earth did he get that hook down his
throat
check out that looks like you got
something over here now it's a Pacific
Cod yeah really good meat yeah they are
oh congratulations
let's go
it's a type of shark right there he
doesn't have a poisonous Thor arm he
just has these little spines on his tail
yeah buddy here you go
we're getting close to
hot start
oh there you go
oh
nice halibut yeah it came up and
everything yeah
[Music]
buddy yeah you wanna block him oh he got
a devil
gonna come under these lines
that's what it's about right there
that's what it's about all right hit it
while we're getting okay
you got that
now you reel it
I think he just got the coolest thing
yeah you got a shark go buddy
it's a dog shark yes look at this they
got it they got a big spine right there
might come hold them that's what it's
about there right yeah
dig what did you think of that yeah
yeah do you see his green eyes Jacob
yeah
yeah nice
all right Jake
I got the hell of it
there we go yeah I can just grab them
nice hell of it buddy
will that halibut like the hooligan so I
guess we'll try some more hooligan
hey
all right it's left over time you know
this shish kebab tastes more like
hooligan than I remember
not sure why
it really is a nice halibut
ES
the tracks
nice
there we go nice big ski
oh
another halibut not too bad
well the Tide's going out pretty good
and it's time to call it I'm tired we've
had a wonderful time oh really in my
rods to go home and there's another
little halibut
[Music]
oh a cute little guy not as big as yours
Jake
do you love that your halibut was bigger
than Daddy's yeah
yeah
oh like
it's been a while since I've done this
by the way now to do the hard one
I forget what I saw just these two
little fish got me loads of fillets that
was fun but we have a long drive back
home if you want to do this too I'll put
a link to Randy's charger service down
in the video description below all right
we gotta get back home we got some fish
to cook
to make some halibut
all right got the skin off
[Music]
foreign
yes so
[Music]
foreign
nuggets just came from half of one fish
that's amazing all right Jake you gonna
have some
more you have some pineapple I know how
hot sauce and no hot sauce in a
different outfit you know he's shown me
a few you don't need one
you got a beautiful halibut tacos with
cilantro lime sauce a little lettuce
pico de gallo yeah not too bad at all
what do you think baby like it
you guys like the tacos was good
excellent excellent awesome out of seven
kids seven of them ate the Halibut I
don't think you can get that with pizza
sometimes you know oh my goodness that
was some good food did you enjoy the
tacos Tom
yeah
lizard I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you want to see more videos
from the outdoor Boys YouTube channel
don't forget to click subscribe we put
out new videos every Saturday if you
like this video don't forget to check
out the outdoor Boys YouTube channel
where we have hundreds of videos just
like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning hit that
Bell button and you'll get notifications
thanks for watching
[Music]